make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin you know last time we made a
video like this
we were talking about like events right
like it gets worse like the events that
could happen
after avengers in-game and it could get
worse i want to talk about thanos
because here's the thing
like non-movie go like i'm sorry not
comic book readers well look at avengers
in-game rightfully so right because like
they don't read comics they're not
really aware
but they'll look at avengers end game
and be like man thanos with the infinity
gauntlet man he's powerful
i guess this is the end times no it's
not either because like thanos is not
that powerful like
here's the thing thanos with the
infinity gauntlet is powerful
sure but he's not like like
number one right it's not like thanos
gets the infinity gauntlet and like
he's unstoppable he's one of the most
powerful beings in the universe but he's
not the most powerful being in the
universe
here's a crazy thing all right so i
could probably i mean okay let's let's
do that there's like there's
like off the top of my head there's like
five people roughly and there's probably
more than that but there's like five
people i can think of just like that
who could probably defeat thanos some it
would take longer than others but they
could probably defeat thanos when he's
wielding the power of the infinity
gauntlet so um okay the first one would
probably be like classic doctor strange
right like
old school doctor strange 1960s to early
1970s doctor strange and here's the
reason why
back when doctor strange first showed up
magic was just like whatever it was a
license to do whatever you wanted to do
if doctor strange wanted to like alter
the very fabric of reality
and turn everybody in the universe into
teddy bears there was a spell for that
like like he could just be like no and
do that do that weird thing with his
hands you know and then like
the spell is done like there were no
rules there was no there was no limit to
what it is that he could do
now this changed twice actually the
first time it changed in december of 19
um december of 1992
and the first well really the the first
time was in 1976
and the second time was in 92. so in
1976 there was a story by marv wolfman
which was kind of weird
and it involved these guys called the
creators and the whole basis was that
they were like extra dimensional beings
and they showed up in the main marvel
universe and
they want to turn like the stars into
their own source of energy it was
crazy it was a wonky and weird story
like most of them were with dr strange i
mean
he literally started in a line of comics
called strange tales so
i guess it kind of makes sense that it's
supposed to be strange and kooky and
weird and so on
in any event over the course of the
story doctor strange loses the mantle of
sorcerer supreme and all the powers that
go with it
and then eventually he gets it back but
his powers are reduced slightly now
why does this matter well because fast
forward you know almost 20 years then
infinity gauntlet happens and so
doctor strange during the events of
infinity gauntlet is not as powerful as
he was in like
1965 or 66 or 67 or any of those
like if if it was classic doctor strange
he would just be like spell cast and
then
like that would be it but there has to
be a spell to remove the infinity
gauntlet
to eliminate the power of the infinity
gauntlet to shut it down and like
he would use that spell and then the
conflict would be done now the second
time that happened
is when doctor strange lost a huge
amount of his power right like it was
called the war of the seven spheres
and this dealt with a group called the
vashanti now when it comes to doctor
strange stephen strange does not
actually have any power unto himself
he uses the powers of others right like
they lend their power to him
most of the power he gets comes from the
vishanti which is a triumvirate it's
three people like watum so on and so
forth during the war of the seven
spheres which was like this prophesized
conflict between like all these magical
entities that existed throughout the
marvel universe that that some
somewhere along the line they were gonna
go to war with each other and so when
that happened doctor strange was
recruited by the bashanti to fight in
their war but
he declined he turned them down and said
like i'm not leaving earth my duty is
here
i'm this universal sorcerer supreme i
don't fight on your behalf and so they
said okay fine
and they took away all the power that
they allowed him to use and so his power
was reduced by like 60
now eventually doctor strange went away
for a little while that led him to
brother voodoo and then doctor strange
came back
but when he did he had far less power
than he did before
and he's basically been at that power
ever since during hickman's avengers and
new avengers he tried to sell his soul
for 100
power and it didn't work but still like
like he's you know
classic doctor strange was crazy
powerful nowadays not so much he's a
stopgap measure he does some cool spells
every once in a while
but he's vastly weaker in comparison to
where he used to be right now
after doctor strange um i'd say protege
protege that's the crazy thing proteges
power project's ability to
to control to to use his powers his
power is mimicry
basically protege can copy the powers of
anybody that he sees
and there's no upper limit but it's not
even really like the power they wield
i guess it's not really like powers
innate to them it's any kind of power
whatsoever
right and like the infinity gauntlet
just harnesses the power of the universe
that's all it does
basically it harnesses the power of time
travel of the ability to read minds
that harnesses the power of like you
know space itself like teleporting from
one location to the next
the ability to to alter the fundamental
forces of reality that's all it is like
it basically allows you to control this
it's it turns the universe into clay and
you can turn that clay into whatever you
want
whatever you want it to be protege if
fighting thanos would
look at the power of the infinity
gauntlet when thanos used it and then
immediately be able to copy that power
right so like if thanos was fighting
protege
or or like you know the two of them are
staring each other down and thanos like
like wheels the wheels the infinity
gauntlet you know use the infinity
gauntlet and turns protege into a statue
protege would turn himself back because
he would know he would he would look at
that and say okay
i can duplicate that power now all he
has to do is watch someone use it now
ideally for protege to defeat thanos
protege would be look we would be
watching thanos
and like watch him use the power of the
infinity gauntlet on other people
and then duplicate those powers and at
that point it would run into a stalemate
um anybody who can wield a cosmic cube
can defeat thanos because the cosmic
cubes
and the infinity gauntlet are equal in
power right like it's just two different
means and the reason why is because the
cosmic cubes
are the powers of the beyonder and that
leads us into the beyonders like
molecule man and the beyonder
are basically one and the same right
like that was established in the
in like fantastic four 214 or something
like that the unofficial sequel to
secret wars in
in you know 1984 because the way this
worked out originally
is like one day like all the heroes and
villains showed up on two separate ships
right like you had the villains on one
ship you had the heroes on the other
ship
and then like some disembodied voice
from a rift in the universe
shows up and says like i am from beyond
you know all you guys basically have to
fight each other to the death and
whoever wins i will give you whatever
your heart desires
and like that was it right like galactus
was there and galactus was like i desire
to not hunger all the time so he went to
go attack the beyonder and was like
brushed off you know and it was it was
kind of crazy but
um at the same time you had the molecule
man owen reese
and during the events of secret wars dr
doom was talking to owen reese and
basically said hey look
you walk around with this stupid little
wand because you had your experiment
that allowed you to you know basically
like manipulate reality in a localized
space
but the truth is that you can manipulate
reality on a multiversal scale
you just have mental blocks in place
because you don't you don't have any
confidence you don't believe in yourself
and owen reese went forward is like this
multiversal force like he was
it was crazy he was more powerful than
living tribunal he was more he was more
powerful than
everyone right like it was it was insane
how much power he had
like thanos comes walking along with the
infinity gauntlet it was like molecule
man oh and reese i challenge you to a
fight he'd be like
and like wave his hand and that would be
the end of that and like that it would
it would it would take nothing now
eventually all that changes right like
you know where the beyonder and the
molecule man owen reese were considered
like two distinctly different beings
that what ended up happening is in the
unofficial secret wars three again like
this
weird little fantastic four story that
you end up learning about like the
nature of the beyonders right like you
have the beyonder
then you have the beyonders and the way
this worked out is the beyonders were
from like the beyond realm right like
just this
place outside the multiverse where time
passed in a linear fashion
they couldn't travel forwards or
backwards but they were basically way
beyond the power of almost anybody that
we'd ever seen
that ever existed in the marvel
multiverse right like possibly even the
one above all although that was never
really confirmed and what ended up
happening is that when
cosmic cubes are created in marvel
comics then what you do is you basically
open up a portal to the realm of the
beyonders
and siphon some of that energy off and
when the molecule man owen reese first
gained his powers from his experiment
what he did was create a cosmic cube the
problem is that there was no containment
cube for that energy to go into
and so half the energy went into owen
reese and the other half just kind of
dissipated out into the universe
and became the beyonder from the first
secret wars and so when all that took
place
basically what you had is you had a guy
owen reese who was like
you know this omniversal you know super
powerful guy
who was essentially just like a walking
talking cosmic cube and that was
basically what it was now eventually all
that gets changed and they kind of get
you know beyond her and molecule man get
merged into like a singular cosmic cube
and it gets kind of weird but
that brings in the beyonders like during
the whole thing about the honors like
thanos with the infinity gauntlet
wouldn't stand a chance not
a chance these were guys who destroyed
the living tribunal right like
like to give you perspective here you
have the events of infinity gauntlet
then you have the infinity gauntlet
aftermath and then the infinity gauntlet
aftermath adam warlock gets the gets the
gauntlet and then like stops the whole
conflict
and then is immediately taken to like
the what is it the dimension of
manifestations or whatever it is and
it's basically taken to like this realm
where like all the cosmic entities meet
and they put them on trial and like
eternity and infinity and the living you
know the the entities in the main marvel
universe basically saying
that guy cannot wield the infinity
gauntlet thanos just wanted to replace
me eternity as like
the top cosmic entity this guy wants to
rule alongside me it's an imbalance of
magical energy
and what you end up learning is that
when adam warlock got the infinity
gauntlet
he purged good and evil from himself and
so he was neither good nor evil he just
existed there was no there was no
telling what it was that he was going to
do
he didn't really sway either way now
during this whole trial adam warlock
like freaks out right he's just like
whatever you guys can't tell me what to
do
i've got absolute power and a living
tribunal is like no you don't either and
like shuts down the infinity gauntlet
and it's just this it's literally just
like this giant glove thing on his hand
with some really pretty jewels and
that's really all it is that that's
like after like the infinity or the the
living tribunal literally waves his hand
and like that's the end of that like
it's done and so like like you're
talking about somebody that powerful
right who can just
shut down the infinity gauntlet without
a blink all right during jonathan
hickman's avengers and new avengers like
the multiversal collapse is happening
nobody knows why the multiverse is
coming to an end and why worlds are
crashing into each other universes
are crashing into each other and so on
and so in the early days when it all
first happens when reed richards finds
out about it when iron man first finds
out about it in black panther and all
those guys
and they reform the illuminati secretly
um
um like reed richards mr fantastic the
fantastic four
sends ant-man uh um uh hank pym
sends hank pam into the multiverse and
says hey find out what's going on
and along the way he sees some crazy
stuff so he comes back right like later
on he comes back and says hey look
like we're we're all basically gonna die
like there's pretty much nothing we can
do
and they're like well what do you mean
man there's gotta be a chance he's like
no you don't understand
what's happening out there like as far
as you're aware
it's just like universes crashing into
each other and
like the best we can do is destroy
another world before it crashes in ours
and save our universe
that's what you're doing all right i was
floating through space
and like i was i was like floating
through and like in and out of different
universes
and then eventually i stumble across the
beyonders the white lords of wild space
just massacring cosmic entities just
like wiping out celestials and all these
different galactuses
and like the living tribunal like just
wiping them all out like literally just
killing them all
and it all it's all happening across
every single universe all at the same
time
and it's he's like it's the most insane
thing i've ever seen
i have never seen any or any group of
people
that have just walked into a universe
and just destroyed all the cosmic
entities
they never had a chance like it's it's
it was it was a massacre right like
it was it it was
crazy like it was it was it was the most
bonkers thing
that i've ever seen and and like you
take those guys right like who can
destroy the living tribunal like
and and here's the thing it took three
of them right like three of them just
blasted
the living tribunal never even had a
chance that's the thing it wasn't like
this long drawn out fight but through
the living tribunal and the beyonders
that spanned like
a whole comic like 22 pages no no
no that that [ __ ] was three pages long
it was it was
it was a living tribe you know showing
up like it shows up like this right just
like
bam like hey you know hank pym's like i
turned around and i couldn't believe
what i was seeing the multiverse given
form
and like the living tribunal standing
out there like that it's like i'm
passing judgment on you and the beyond
just like don't care and like the three
were just like bam and they literally
destroyed the living tribunal
and a piece of him falls in every single
universe like like
are you no way thanos with the infinity
gauntlet would stand a chance
not a chance like you've got mad jim
jasper's with the jasper's warp here's
the problem
matt jim jasper's with the jasper's
wharf that would take time
the jasper's warp takes time to emanate
out from from jim jasper's himself
and spread throughout the the universe
and eventually into the multiverse now
we know how powerful it was because
during the original story on earth
238 or whatever it was with the original
jim jaspers who wasn't even as powerful
as the main marvel version
but like the original jim jaspers when
the jasper's warp emanated
they had to destroy his universe
otherwise the jasper's warp would have
spread into the multiverse and literally
like just torn it all asunder and
screwed everything up so they had to
wipe his universe from existence in
order to stop him he was so
powerful they had to nullify his
universe
they had to wipe it off the face of the
off the face of the multiverse so they
wouldn't become a threat to anybody else
they quarantined it
and it was it was like okay like and and
you you look at that and
no way standoff with the infinity
gauntlet has a chance against that guy
here's here's the thing thanos with the
infinity gauntlet is powerful
but he's just not that powerful like
there was one point in the comics when
galactus died
and then you realize that what galactus
was doing was basically like he was a
gatekeeper
for abraxas and like abraxas comes out
abroad
he represents the like he's he's just
pure rampage
like pure destruction abraxas jumps from
one universe to the next just
hopping from one universe to the next
wiping out galactuses
like like just killing every single
galactus he comes across just like
wiping them all out without batting an
eye the guy's the representation of
multiverse of destruction like
what it takes is it's like literally
franklin richards resurrecting galactus
from the dead
and then giving him the ultimate
nullifier and then pointing it at
abraxas and like wiping him out or maybe
it's maybe it's
uh reed richards who does it but it
takes the ultimate nullifier right like
this plot device it takes a plot device
to wipe him out
the ultimate nullifier is just a device
you use to point at something and then
like it never existed
and like that's that's literally all it
is the leading out cosmic entities like
abraxas
there are people out there who would
just crush you know thanos with the
infinity gauntlet anybody really the
heart of the universe
would obliterate him like thanos with
the infinity gauntlet is
not that powerful he's powerful but he's
not
like the end times powerful it's not
like the buck stops here
no it doesn't like the buck stops here
on its way to what's next like that's
literally how that works
that's the thing that's that's that is
man
casual moviegoers you guys who don't
usually read comics
you you are not prepared
there are so many things out there
that are way beyond the power of thanos
with the infinite on
if dormammu left the the the dark
dimension
and showed up in full power in the main
marvel dimension
not a chance thanos would be able to
defeat him man god would probably not
fall to thanos
man god can wield magical energy more so
than that man god's immortal
indestructible and
cannot be defeated like like as long as
hatred exists
the only way for thanos to successfully
defeat man god is to wipe out all life
in the universe
and then become a being of pure good
that has no form of hatred whatsoever
and then man god would be de-powered and
when i say all life i mean
every living organism like everything
that could possibly feel any emotion
whatsoever
would have to be wiped out because if it
can feel hate
man god will continue to exist at
absolute like
like peak power and man god as he exists
right now isn't even man god from like
the 1980s
in 1982 he was a hoss it was it was nuts
man gog is like the only thing that odin
was afraid of right like
like man gog would storm asgard and no
one would be like dude man we are
screwed
like dude run that's what it would come
down to
fleeing for your lives like that's
literally what it would turn into like
man god storms asgard like
they're all gonna die like that like
there are beings out there that are just
crazy powerful in comparison to thanos
like even with the infinity gauntlet so
it gets kind of nuts when you start
getting into this whole thing with
comics like
fans with the infinity gauntlet sure
it's cool and it looks pretty
and it can probably sell for a pretty
penny like for a lot of money
but like for real though like he's just
not that powerful
not in comparison i mean here's the
thing in comparison to like
99 of the population out there or the
various super beings out there
sure thanos with the infinity wall they
could defeat them but for that one
percent
they would crush him and not even buy a
little bit like i mean by a lot like
they would they would mock the floor
with him like they would absolutely
obliterate him
and it wouldn't even be fair like it
wouldn't it wouldn't even be funny like
it would just be
it would be thanos just like like coming
along with those little infinity
gauntlet like oh you know and then it
would just be like they were just
pummeling they would they would
just like shut the gauntlet down and
then just and then that would be it
because when you're talking about beings
whose power
transcends the singular universe no way
thanos can stand a chance because you're
talking about a being who could affect
who can control energy and matter on a
multiversal scale
they could turn the infinity gauntlet
into corn flakes like that's literally
what they could do right like just
thanos is just like huh you know like
i've got the infinity gauntlet no you
don't you got a box of wheaties on your
hand
so go back home and like you would look
at it and just be a giant box of
wheaties on his hand like that's that's
what it would that's what they could do
like it'd be it'd be kind of bonkers so
yeah
uh avengers in-game is awesome but
if they stick with the comics and they
give us some of the beings that are out
there
like that's it's it's it's only the tip
of the iceberg like it'll
it'll be like full metal alchemist right
like you think you know what's going on
and then you get to the end and then you
realize you had no idea what was going
on
and you kind of longed for the day when
it was just like
some girl being merged with a dog like
like it gets kind of bonkers you know i
know people are gonna be like don't
bring up nina
dude that was cool i actually thought it
was kind of a cool little thing like it
was it was kind of wild i was like this
is like a girl dog
it's kind of creepy but kind of cool at
the same time with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to
an end if you are new here to comments
explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop some likes drop some
likes
drop some likes right now and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you